hey guys and welcome back to the Leia
Heil pen show today we are talking about
whether Bitcoin is the ultimate store
value and a medium of exchange joining
me to debate this is epic cash Community
volunteer and podcast host Uncle
vigilante welcome to the show how are
you greetings I'm fine thank you for
having me this is a real pleasure today
yeah I'm excited to speak with you we've
spoken to the epicache Community First
we had a little bit of a Bitcoin versus
epic debate so I'm excited to sort of
redo that but learn a little bit more um
you know and teach more to um all of our
all of our viewers so before we jump
into all of this you have a big
background in disruptive technology so
talk to me about that why are you the
guy that can tell me about epic cash
basically so disruptive technology has
been part of my DNA for the last 25
years people are familiar with
priceline.com well I remember when we
founded priceline.com in a little room
in our office two servers and
priceline.com ultimately
revolutionized the travel industry
before and you're you're younger so you
probably don't remember back in the day
where for you to be able to travel you'd
have to call a travel agency and Thomas
Cook was you know the biggest in the
world and everything but with
priceline.com now not only could you go
online and be able to book your travel
you could compare all of the other
Airlines and they would basically Vie
for your dollar and the the best price
wins and so uh priceline.com at one
point in time we were valued more than
all of the airlines combined in the U.S
and since then our company we uh have
had six one billion dollar exits and
Tech that that what we focus on is
revolutionary Tech the little guys that
disrupt the big guys not always the
first movers but the little guys and uh
just for example Priceline disrupted the
travel industry right Apple disrupted
the music industry Amazon disrupted the
book uh bookstore industry and Uber
disrupted the transportation industry uh
lastly Netflix disrupted the
entertainment industry so
um you know the question
that is going to be relevant today uh
will crypto currencies disrupt the
financial system what say you oh
I'm the US government the SEC you know
the the IMF and you know how terrified
they are how you know how Regulators are
behaving they know that it's going to be
so disruptive um but the question is is
it Bitcoin or is it going to be
something else I personally think it's
Bitcoin okay
um um you know and I I do personally
think it's that Medium of exchange and
that um ultimate store of value you just
have to look at the chart over the last
10 years
um but I know that fungibility is an
issue for for you for the epicache
community you sort of feel Bitcoin Isn't
So fungible so talk to me about this and
let's see if maybe we can find some
common ground somewhere sure sure if you
don't mind though because I want to kind
of put a bookend on the disruptive text
sure is
um just asking you four questions okay
you can answer them all at the end uh
was Apple the First music this uh this
Distribution Company was Amazon the
first book Distribution Company was Uber
the first private transportation company
was net Netflix the first of the inner
in the entertainment business and the
answer of course is no is no right so uh
the question is do you think that
Bitcoin and this is going to hurt some
of the the viewers ears I'll be persona
non Gratis but I'm just going to say it
okay do you think that Bitcoin with its
open public surveillance Ledger
inability to scale confiscatable coins
non-fungible and centralized nature will
underpin this financial services uh
disruption well that's if you believe
all of those things are accurate and
that's what we're going to discuss okay
good let's do it let's start with
fungibility I think Bitcoin is fungible
I understand that you don't think it's
fungible so tell me why do you not think
Bitcoin is fungible
uh
fungibility and
um
you're you're better with names uh the
gentleman Jason who wrote the book Jason
yeah uh can I swear on here yeah I think
so
he wrote Bitcoin
um uh hard money you can't [__] with
right so
fungibility to me means you can't [__]
with it
at all
and yet what has happened time and time
again we were talking about
um not George but uh moon right who he
just shared recently that he was not
able to deposit his Bitcoin to an
exchange because they identified that
had been through a mixer
there are those stories all over the
place to where these exchanges they they
uh they they have these Services which
allow uh uh nefarious parties to be able
to determine based upon your Bitcoin
address whether or not that the history
of that coin all the way back to minting
has ever been used for illegal purposes
if it has they can Blacklist it that's
[__] with your Bitcoin so no I don't
believe it's fungible because one coin
is not exactly the same as the other
coin and if if if you disagree with me
just please tell me how on Earth can
your Bitcoin ever be denied based upon
forensic analysis
um of which I have for you what is this
more examples no this is uh uh chain
surveillance firms oh I see yeah do you
realize that that is a 20 billion dollar
industry
and what I did for you is I ended up
having my guys right take someone's uh
Bitcoin address he happened to be the uh
the the founder of uh Komodo right he
has gone his whole life of being totally
uh Anonymous and he successfully done it
so far but what we do know about him is
in one place he posted his Bitcoin
address after that I have just pages and
pages and pages of everything in his
wallet that he has ever done since 2013.
now each one of those where he sends it
to someone and there's another address
that opens up another giant rabbit hole
to where these chain analysis companies
can go and they can determine uh that
wallet any of those wallets that have
received any coins that have been deemed
to be uh part of any illicit or illegal
legal activity can totally can totally
and it's only getting more uh nefarious
out there uh can totally
um they they can they can lock down your
coins so that to me is not fungible
please tell me why you think it is so I
agree with you this is this is pretty
crazy
um that's one thing which I don't
necessarily love about Bitcoin the fact
that it isn't highly traceable and um
that's not the only example you know I
know that you know Bitcoin coming out of
like North Korea coming out of Russia
um some of the Bitcoin from the truckers
protests all of these have been
blacklisted
um however I would not say that that
means Bitcoin isn't fungible I would say
that's a centralized issue that's an
issue with Regulators an issue with
these
um centralized exchanges who will do
whatever they can to shut down Bitcoin
because they haven't done anything to
the Bitcoin right like when we talk
about fungibility I from from my
perspective it's talking about the
fungibility of the asset itself so for
example if I give you a one dollar bill
and you give and you have a one dollar
bill and my one dollar bill is ripped up
and I want to try and switch it it's not
going to be the same that's not fungible
because now I've actually damaged that
one dollar bill
and so now it's not fungible but with
the Bitcoin from my perspective it
doesn't mean that it's not it's not not
fungible it's still one Bitcoin still
equals one Bitcoin that's a centralized
issue not equal one Bitcoin why not
because you can go out there and you can
for a 20 premium you can buy freshly
minted Bitcoin
and
I I believe that we even sent uh some
examples to you on that where people are
buying that so why is that because you
definitely no I mean you definitely can
and I think um you can with many
different things
um that's just what the market might
prefer but it doesn't mean that one
Bitcoin isn't one Bitcoin like I
personally have never met anyone that
would say sorry I won't accept your
Bitcoin
um I want more yeah but these people are
20 billion dollar industry and you tell
me I admire you greatly because uh uh uh
you know I think fortune favors the
Brave and Bold and you have
um a giant set of of you know you know
what it's you speak truth to power and
that's what I admire about you so much
and you're not very popular in some
points yeah that's true even BTC I was
just astonished at how much [__] you're
getting from the BTC
um oranges I don't know what well it's
because I have conversations like this
they wouldn't have these conversations
thank you for that oh it's my it's my
pleasure I take more [__] for it it's
okay it's okay and you will again
because people have
um confirmation bias and and uh if it's
not Bitcoin it's a [__] coin come on I
talked to you about
um about the first mover Tech I mean
about the uh what was it here
um
is Yahoo or AOL still king of search
is Friendster or my state space still on
top in social media why did Facebook
have to buy Instagram why did Google
have to buy YouTube why do you engage in
the uh in the world with that Sleek
little computer that you have right
where you're checking the Bitcoin price
why do you do that instead of a
Blackberry but there are still
Blackberry Maxis out there I'm sure
really but when I talk to you about my
track record we have 22 portfolio
companies that are all focused on
disruptive Tech not in a million years
would we ever uh uh hand wave an
emerging technology I will tell you if
you want to just talk about what what is
epic cash just because we're an
Undiscovered coin we are 25 million
market cap that's laughable right that's
laughable but let me tell you what we
are
I submit to you that if Satoshi Nakamoto
had access to today's technology
and the learnings of the last decade an
insight into the the the the
wef overlords and everything that
they're trying to do to control us
if he could rewind pulling back today's
technology because you have to admit
Tech advances right technology
mimblewimble was not available to
Satoshi Nakamoto in 2008. I submit to
you Satoshi Nakamoto would have wanted
Bitcoin to be a private Ledger he
wouldn't perhaps I I mean I I don't know
I think that maybe that's something
which he considered and thought no it's
probably he doesn't have the technology
there wasn't the technology and and for
surveillance it wasn't an issue to him
because there was no nefarious parties
out there willing to step up and say
whoa this is getting to be serious it
got to a trillion dollars you know now
it's a half a trillion dollars right but
he didn't ever think that he he was
thinking about this disruption was
peer-to-peer exchange of value right
it's no longer that I ca you can't go
peer-to-peer now you can say oh no you
can well if you're running a node and
I'm running a node but you know what
percentage of of people in this world
are running their own nodes how many one
percent yeah I mean I I definitely think
online centralized exchanges so you're
talking about what you just said was
it's an issue of centralization one
Bitcoin equals but but but but really to
me that's kind of going like this
because the fact of the matter 99 of the
people are not exchanging peer-to-peer
so I think we should teach people how to
exchange pay-to-peer we should teach
people how to run a node we should teach
people the importance do you know how
expensive it is to run a node of course
it's expensive yeah how can how can
the 1.8 billion unbanked people in this
world
send any amount of anything to anyone
for less than a penny
uh without being surveilled
without anybody being able to mess with
that transaction I think I think it's
important to make a distinction between
anonymity and traceability because it's
not like Bitcoin is
um
entirely it you know it's not like you
have to add your identification number
you have to there's no social security
no there's no name there's no there's no
identification right and so so that that
to be you know intellectually honest
it's good to you know make sure that we
know that that it is anonymous although
it is entirely traceable I mean I think
it's entirely Anonymous unless you make
a mistake that's human error it is
entirely Anonymous the guy from Komodo
that's the guy from Komodo that's human
error people add their add their wallet
addresses on um have you ever seen on
emails address to anyone by email or by
text uh yes but yes I have and that's
human error and as a result I've opened
up new I've opened up new wallets and
throwing those wallets away and and what
is The Human Condition right it's the
path of least resistance we like easy
you look out there I don't know about
you
pretty pretty familiar with your world
view which I share you know
I'm not an NPC you're not an NPC and I
don't know about you but I never wore a
mask and I believe that there are you
know
95 of the people out there who are just
going to be go along to get along I I
honestly I understand I understand the
convenience argument but some things in
life are worth learning like I always
say I prefer I prefer um you know
democracy overconvenience like I for
example in the UK I voted to to leave
the EU because I think democracy above
convenience right people said to us well
then you know now you're not gonna be
able to live abroad and you're not you
know your cheap flights are going to be
gone and I said well democracy over
convenience and so I prefer
decentralization and security over
convenience a lot of the alternatives to
bitcoin aren't as sorry aren't as
decentralized they aren't as secure
they've been hacked
um and so for me personally it's
convenience over over sorry it's not
convenience over everything so you'd
mention that it's worth learning new
things right so I presume you were
talking about maybe learning nodes yeah
and everything is one step at a time how
to be able to uh be mindful and not you
know so not uh send your BTC address or
not post it in your show notes if you're
wanting donations and stuff like that
right yeah
um but when you say that why does it
seem that you aren't open to really
understanding new things like what
private Bitcoin could be because I'm
telling you may I may I
would you mind I was thinking all the
way here I was driving down from Tampa
down here and I was thinking about what
is my clothes going to be right and I
would just like to it's just four
paragraphs I just like to read it to you
it summarizes everything that I feel and
I think just in these few words it'll
let people know what I believe epic cash
is if that's okay of course thank you
all right
which people in the world have the most
to lose
those suffering from controlling
centralized oppressive corrupt
governments corporations and financial
institutions so many of us have already
been so many of us have already been
victims of Lawless mandates censorship
and confiscation of private property
ultimately there becomes a fear of being
un being able to participate in the
world as we've always known it now
here's my fundamental belief especially
considering the 1.8 billion unbanked in
the world I believe epic cash will be
like America was before its founding a
land of Freedom centralization free
censorship free surveillance free
unconfiscatable private property with
our Advanced Tech we can privately send
epic cash anywhere anytime to anyone for
any amount for less than a penny within
seconds with no transaction history
forever entered onto the blockchain
moreover no one can stop our exchange of
value honest pro-liberty money
permissionless private payments it's the
power of disruptive innovation the power
of compounding ideas Innovation
reasserting itself epic cash
unconfiscated private property for the
masses so to me that's what it's all
about and I don't I don't know why
anyone out there who has the capacity to
truly critically think would take a look
at something and not
um not at least explore
you know what is it about this Advanced
Tech that can that can truly allow you
to exchange value privately peer-to-peer
for less than a penny you know that that
we have we have uh thousands of people
in Africa that are downloading the Epic
pay wallet and they're starting to
exchange value in Africa you know
ultimately what is money money is what
people agree it is as a medium of
exchange right we learned a lot of from
the Africans because they are so smart
they when the oppressive government over
there uh put their you know their their
Jack boot on their throats
they started exchanging value in Orange
minutes
cellular minutes
so they get it and they are exchanging
value over in Africa right now uh uh
epic cash and
um uh from a use case standpoint I'll
give you a little bit of insight
um I don't know if uh you're familiar
with Mike Adams or not but he is uh he
is the founder of bradyon.com which you
may want to get familiar with Leia
because it is a decentralized uh uh
decentralized YouTube If you will okay
no one is ever going to be able to
censor you and so he has people who uh
stream on bradyon which he is like look
this is about
freedom to voice it's it's not about
this faux Freedom that uh you know
Twitter is not right yeah and and uh he
took a look at us and he spent two
months doing his due diligence on
bitcoin versus versus epic cash versus
Monero he wanted to basically take his
business which is a hundred million
dollars a year of of food right
um think of think about things for for
Preppers right people who think about
the future he wanted to be able to get
off of Fiat and start denominating in a
cryptocurrency and he selected epic cash
so I can now speak about the fact that
this little bitty crypto that could
is going to be part of this Empire to
where people will get a discount by
using epic cash and it's private that's
what he said he was like you know what I
love about it is there's gonna be a day
when the cbdc's kick in and they're
going to uh they're going to say Leia
now
I know that you enjoyed that nice steak
dinner the first week but now we're in
the last week and you want to have
another steak and they say no you kind
of exceeded your carbon footprint there
and so you can't programmable money
right people who aren't awake to what
these cbdc's are going to do to your um
to your freedom
you're just not paying attention but
with Mike he's like I love the idea to
where people can use epic cash to
privately buy food when the Druid
Babylonian bastards tell them they can't
so it's it's backed by uh epic cash
backed by food we're working on a gold
provider who is going to accept epic
cash so epic cash backed by gold I'm
just saying don't believe me just just
just do your own research epiccash.com
is a great place to start
I I that I wasn't necessarily
open-minded to what could be better than
Bitcoin yeah I definitely am okay
um you know that's why we're having this
conversation yes
um you know I I do a lot of research
about privacy coins I'm actually a huge
fan of privacy coins um for the reason
we've we've just mentioned yeah
um however Bitcoin is the only one so
far that has proven itself over time you
know you said in 2021 you could only
just spell blockchain right so you you
weren't in the space
um and so for so for me
we need that we need time is everything
and so
the longer epic cash exists the longer I
have the ability to make a better
analysis a question
again I approach everything uh with with
I approach everything based upon how we
would view uh startup that we would buy
right and you have to be able to look at
past performance yeah
do you believe that three years like if
we rewound three years and compared
performance
um that that is fair let's just talk now
I know that you uh recently had your
gold conversation with Peter right
um
if you went back would it be fair to be
able to say in 2020 in March March 13th
there was the the black Thursday crypto
crash do you remember that very well
it's where the Boogie virus came out and
oh no the world is not going to be here
tomorrow everybody's gonna die and all
cryptocurrencies boom it was horrible
right so we believe that that's a really
good starting point to be able to do an
analysis and what we did and I have it
and I'd love to be able to just share it
with you because
Bill Parcells famous football coach
he had the best quote ever
and it's you are what your record says
you are so when you talk about
epic cash and Bitcoin and Bitcoin having
you know all of this history all of
these years granted right and then
better Tech came along for privacy you
said you like privacy coins Monero in
2014. okay but Monero their blockchain
like uh BTC bloats because you're
literally carrying every transaction
each time I send it uh uh all the way
back to original minting so right now
the uh uh Bitcoin I think is 450
gigabyte blockchain right and that's
just because it has to care I always
joke I'm like I imagine if I went back
to when I was born and never went to the
bathroom but I just consumed all the
food and it's like that Monty Python guy
and remember that where uh he's like
full golf I'm full you know he just got
bigger and bigger then he blew up so
that's the inherent design of Bitcoin
and Monero holds that transaction
information as well with epic cash
because of the amazing technology called
mimblewimble
um and cut through technology and
dandelion technology it's basically
every time I send a coin to anybody it's
like it smelted down like if you imagine
it being a gold coin it's smelted down
with all of the others and then it is
sent and all the blockchain knows is
that one left mine and one went into
your wallet there is no transaction
information not anything about me not
anything about you mimblewimble
technology just does the math and it
knows in in the wallets where that uh uh
the Delta is of that coin thus we don't
carry any data in the blockchain which
makes it amazingly scalable that's why
and that was a big part of it when Mike
Adams said you know I can't afford to do
Bitcoin I can't afford to have my he
can't afford to do Bitcoin what do you
mean this guy's uh was he multi-million
I can't afford to do like you can't
afford two three four five dollars on a
transaction transact in bit he can't
afford no because why what happened last
week 24 hours you couldn't send a
Bitcoin you could it was just extremely
expensive because of ordinals and
everything you have but there are
scaling Solutions there are scaling
Solutions all of these it's like yeah
but yeah but well no but I mean I could
do the same with epic cash you guys have
been around for for how long uh we've
been around since 2018. okay okay and so
you haven't really stood the test of
time yeah talk about that later sure
let's talk about let's talk about it and
also I want to go back to your point for
a second about Bitcoin crashing in um
2020 yeah I perfectly stood the test of
time excuse me it perfectly stood the
test of time that was that was
incredible that's incredible I like I I
feel like you're using that as a reason
why it's like no no bad but it's it's
brilliant because we printed
unprecedented amounts of money number
one if you use it as a store of value
and you bought in March 2020 and you and
you held it until now well you're up
what thousands of percent get if you
want to do the maths what are you up for
for yes thousands of percent I can't
think of the top of my head
um and then yeah so you're up thousands
of percent as a as a store of value
um we printed unprecedented amounts of
money we had a pandemic we had a
lockdown yeah we had um soaring
inflation and yet Bitcoin as always is
rising from the dead
I mean I don't know any other
cryptocurrency other than ethereum that
has been able to perform in such a way
and be widely adopted and used and you
know whether Bitcoin is a medium of
exchange or whether it's a store of
value I think is yet to be decided and
the market will decide that you know if
you talk about it has issues scaling
well you know we can look to lightning
and we can we can talk about that
um I mean it works it's just not mass
adopted yet
um but how many Bitcoins are on the
lightning Network I actually don't know
how many four thousand none I mean like
I said it hasn't scaled yet it hasn't it
hasn't been Mass adopted I mean no it
works because it doesn't work it works
you know I've opened up lightning
channels and been able to transact but
no it's not mass adopted I gotta go you
gotta pay to get in pay to get off it's
not very expensive that's not very
expensive you do you just open up a
channel and it can be but it's not that
expensive that's like sending one
Bitcoin to another yes
actually get your Bitcoin to move last
week or two weeks that's that's a
special occasion that's a very special
occasion so don't open Lightning
channels when when the network is
congested when we're talking about uh
Mike Adams when he what he was saying
was he can't transact in Bitcoin is he
can't have his uh his customers sending
Bitcoin in and paying 84 bucks or 20
bucks but that's but that's just a very
rare occasion that's a very rare
occasion two bucks okay two bucks if you
are the unbanked you may only make two
dollars a day there's 1.8 billion
unbanked out there I disagree with that
sentiment I really disagree with that
sentiment what's disagreeable about that
so I understand that those that are
unbanked are obviously in you know worse
economies they they make two dollars a
day however what I will say is the great
thing about blockchain technology
Bitcoin aside this is actually one of
the things that I loved about the space
when I first got into it was the fact
that it does put people on the financial
map but what that means is it means that
it opens up the global economy and so
those people who are only earning two
dollars a day within their own economy
now or on the financial map and have the
ability to earn so much more by doing
business with the rest of the world as
an example I
um I needed somebody to redo my website
the guy in the US was going to charge me
I think five or seven thousand dollars I
hired somebody I can't remember maybe he
was in Pakistan I can't remember I had
somebody
um and I gave him a thousand dollars for
it so so now he can be competitive right
he can now compete he makes more money
he makes more money since I'm base here
he's working with people based in
America as opposed to People based on
his own country who will only pay him
you know two dollars a day so when
you're unbanked right so so I I don't
buy the whole oh these poor people are
only on two dollars a day no when you're
unbanked and you're working with crypto
you know how to make money I cannot have
access to Bitcoin in a normal way they
have to have access to the financial
institutions no they can't YC they can
just download they can download a
non-custodial wallet and and and get
non-kyc Bitcoin
okay no you disagree huh you disagree
not in Mass not in Mass these people
these people uh they have their mobile
phones right and these people are are
absolutely
um
not welcome by the financial
institutions of course because you need
all the documents and the kyc those
people don't matter they do not matter
to the banksters right so they are
nobody is paying attention to the 1.8
billion dollars unbanked epic cash is
now regarding epic cash versus Bitcoin
that crash in on March 13 2020 as a
starting point
Bill Parcells you are what your record
says you are okay
store value okay
BTC kicked ass okay
BTC has increased
437 percent
against the dollar okay from 4K to now
from 2000 from 2020 when it crashed from
to Last Friday I had it run through last
year I did what was the percentage
percentage was 437 430 check those
numbers while we're here keep talking
please do
epic cash increased 14 215 percent
fourteen thousand two hundred and
fifteen percent well that can happen
when something so uh you know and it has
a very small market cap they they pump
and they dump it's that's renowned you
are what you say you are you know you
have to look at the history of coins
or do you want to be subjective because
right I'm just giving you objective
facts I'm getting I know I'm giving you
an honest response the honest response
is that is what happens when you have
low market cap and when you have like
these small little low Market uh cap
coins they they can do that and then
they can do that but here's let me throw
this out at you you know what about the
notion of not just saying I'm not saying
uh epic cash versus Bitcoin I'm saying
have an open mind to be able to explore
the the tech let me stop this
conversation however I I need time I
need time you know I need to know sure
if you just back then if you just took
10 of your BTC portfolio if you had uh
0.972 BC
TC valued at five thousand dollars in
your portfolio on March thirteenth
twenty how much would it be worth today
if you had converted ten percent of it
to Epic
the answer is if you're 100 BTC today
you would have that five thousand
dollars would be twenty six thousand
eight hundred and seventy one dollars if
you had ninety percent BTC and ten
percent epic you would have this is net
profit ninety five thousand seven
hundred fifty Seven dollars so epic cash
becomes a force multiplier there are
going to be people today who are going
to be watching who are going to hand
wave this conversation and they're gonna
uh Bitcoin or [__] coin and well today
it's a force multiplier tomorrow we'll
see what it is that's like saying to me
if you put if you put like a hundred
dollars into Pepe or a hundred dollars
into Doge at the correct time you would
have you know a thousand three five ten
thousand three years of track record
it's not a lot you know it's not a lot
three years three it's not a lot three
years
it's very small okay I I can do the same
analysis versus versus Monero okay I'm
not a Monaro Maxi I'm just open to the I
like privacy you know there but I have a
question for you I have a question I
have a question for you there's a lot of
different projects that are all looking
to um
create more privacy for the user which I
really like
um you know like you said there's Monero
there's also
um a company called Tommy they've just
released their ethereum privacy layer
and they also have well what they have
is a stable coin a private stable coin
um which I I think is quite interesting
so what makes you different to all the
other projects that are um trying to
create more privacy for the user well
first of all we'll never be declared a
security by the SEC
because we were Fair launched there was
no Ico there was no investment dollars
it was just launched to the wild I think
Monaro is a would be called a security
either Monero wouldn't be called right
so but so right neither would would um
Tommy's privacy later but why are you
different 3 000 coins especially if
you're talking about writing on ethereum
are going to be declared security Warren
has already come out and said that with
her with her anti-crypto Mafia right the
SEC has their has their sights set on
cryptocurrency and let me tell you if
you didn't Fair launch it if if you had
any kind of an Ico if there was any kind
of a pre-mine you're screwed okay so one
day you're either going to get sued or
uh they're just going to legislate you
out of existence
um can I just share with you of course
positive attributes of of Epic cash and
I'm going to give this to you because uh
I did a whole series on my YouTube
channel Uncle vigilante Channel
um called The Quest for Superior money
we did this with the chief engineer of
uh Todd Lewis of Epic cash and he is
this guy who just has a passion for
what is money what is superior money and
so we took 28 shows okay so like almost
40 hours of content it's in my playlist
to where we came up with 30 attributes
that Superior money would have to have
all the way from fungibility
surveillance resistant Fair launch trust
minimally minimized immutable
eco-friendly open government scalable
fast and I'll leave that with you but we
compared epic cash to bitcoin Bitcoin is
eco-friendly what's that bitcoin's
eco-friendly oh my gosh you shouldn't
have put a cross by that you can use you
can't be serious I am very serious now
you sound like those are the world
economic forums now you sound like
people at the world economic Forum what
do you mean of course it is you can use
renewable energy oh my goodness I cannot
believe this so all of those A6 miners
that they have to replace
for tens of billions of dollars every
two years those are going to go into
this this this you know garbage is that
biodegradable it's not eco-friendly I
mean you may have you may have some uh
those Asics miners that are that are
securing the network
you can you can hypothetically talk
about oh no it's eco-friendly because
you can put it under a turbine somewhere
but that's not how they how how well
we're moving towards that and I think
more than four I mean currently more
than 41 of all Bitcoin that his mined
uses renewable energy so there's
definitely a push towards that what
about all of those A6 miners like I said
there's a push towards it there's a push
towards it we're trying to get it more
eco-friendly okay okay well we have to
we have to because there's so much
pressure there's so much pressure from
everyone those are the world economic
forums do you know how we do it tell me
we do it and what and what do you we
created polyphasic proof of work
multi-algo uh eco-friendly mining so 48
of all mining is done on CPUs
48 is done on gpus and four percent on
Asics uh Asics so
literally 48 and 48 are on uh computers
that you don't have to create these you
know from scratch for one use one use
case only and that's to mine it's done
on gaming computers do you know there
are two billion gaming computers that
are out there those can all mine epic
cash now when you're not using it when
you're sleeping and so many people are
we are mining in 138 countries right now
and uh and it's very very profitable for
our Miners and how decentralized is epic
cash uh we have nodes in 140 countries
so we are almost as decentralized as
Bitcoin except we uh just started in
2018 so I think that's pretty
impressively and you have like did you
have a pre-mine or anything no
pre-minded nothing and what's the
distribution of the coins and the
wallets I I need to look into that like
is there a wallet which holds you know a
lot of Epic cash Epic
well first of all it's it's private well
it's private so you can't figure that
one out so we don't know yeah I just
right yeah we don't know but right now
um uh we have uh 15 million coins that
have been mined and uh it is on track to
where in 2008 it'll be the same emission
schedule as Bitcoin that's called the uh
Singularity event then it'll be exactly
the same as them for the next what 100
years or whatever
um we have our next having next month
and you know the way that these proof of
work coins go again we took everything
that was good about Bitcoin so we we pay
great homage to the grandfather of all
cryptos it's just we smartly use
2019 Tech
um uh the mimblewimble technology the
cut through the coin join to be able to
have it so that it's scalable it's
fungible truly fungible and it's private
what is wrong with that this is what
boggles my mind is it's like I speak to
folks that are uh BTC uh uh
cited or I think BTC Maxis who who
literally if it's not Bitcoin it's a
[__] coin I think that that is just
um
I don't know I couldn't operate that way
in my business and look at every up and
coming tech company that we look at 100
throughout the year and just minimize
them because they aren't the first mover
no I agree with you I mean I think you
can have a dogmatic approach to anything
in life but don't you believe that most
people in Bitcoin Community do yes but
that has nothing to do with me I know it
does yeah and I respect that about you
yeah I mean I was talking to a lot of
different people and you know that
they're proud to wear the name toxic
Bitcoin Maxi and you know I'm not like
that I have a very open mind I'm open to
learning more if epic cash is the future
then then so be it you know a funny
story about you know a real toxic
personality but in in Bitcoin American
huddle right he had
um uh Jason was on this it was like I
remember it's like The Brady Bunch to
where there were three people from epic
cash who were interviewed and then there
were these six BTC Maxes and American
huddle was like what's your market cap
at the time it was like 3 million and
you just started
your coins tomorrow
you know and and everything and uh it's
so funny because uh since that point in
time our market cap is now 25 million
Bitcoin was one trillion during that
interview and now it's a half a trillion
and so Market Cycles Market Cycles
Market Cycles it will be back up so
don't mock the little guys what I'm
telling you yeah of course you know like
I said I'm always extremely open-minded
but I think only only time can tell
um and Bitcoin has stood the test of
time
um nothing else it has but I'm really
concerned about it moving forward
because why because of the fundability
because they can [__] with it see that
like I understand until it happens to
you then perhaps maybe that happens to
you maybe you'll be but I don't put my
money on centralized exchanges like I
don't I do not use centralized platforms
whatsoever I always transact
peer-to-peer with everything whether
it's Bitcoin whether it's ethereum
whether it's stable coins good for you I
don't I don't do that that's why this is
the Leia Halpern show right there you go
because you're smart enough to be able
to know how to right and so that's why I
say I don't think that it's a Bitcoin
issue we keep coming back to the same
point like ah this isn't a Bitcoin issue
it's not like somebody is tapped into
the code and changed the code and if
they did change the code well then you
would see a fork in in the road and then
it wouldn't be Bitcoin anymore yeah
yeah well that's exactly that's what I'm
saying exactly so and I don't know what
you're gonna do about these ordinals but
you know to me it's like uh it's funny I
don't have an issue with ordinals either
I think let the market decide what
bitcoin's gonna be wow so you I don't
have an issue
blockchain that you can't move value
um based upon you know people that are
that are that are putting ordinals on
the blockchain I don't have an issue
with so are we not a medium of exchange
anymore well I see this is what I said
at the beginning I said
and that's completely fine and if we
move to something where it's more of a
store of value that's okay too and
perhaps something like epicache would be
the medium of exchange I don't I don't
know but what I do think is that Bitcoin
will be the one that is here to stay
long term I do see it being more of a
digital gold as a store of value and I'd
be open to there being another type of
currency which is used as that Medium of
exchange but I can't win because I throw
out the store of value to where Bitcoin
in the last three years in two months is
up 438 percent and I'm like that's
kicking ass right but then when you take
a look at us being up
2564 not 25 000. yeah that was bothering
me but but uh no but but you're too
thought okay so you're up 400 and more
than 400 400 and 4 000 plus it's called
a thousand percent for four thousand
plus or 37 you're 437 percent
and oh here it is and we have increased
14 215 percent
either way you see those kind of
increases in many different low cap
coins like I said with Doge Pepe that's
there's a whole lot of [__] coins that
have been out there that have pumped and
when did you say you launched 2018 2019
September
the September 2018 sorry 18. okay well
we see that
crypto
um they pump and then they and then they
dump and it can be over the span of a
few years but that's not even one market
said you know in the last three years
Leia we cumulative we are the number one
crypto Currency coin
in the world
in the world to
huh to to do something or you're just
the number one currency in the world no
in in um by what increased uh percentage
okay
increase gain so it happens it doesn't
surprise me it's crypto these things are
small and they're volatile and they jump
thousands of coins out there can you at
least give us credit that hey that's
pretty good I mean I remember it has
been over three years right that that
ever since our Inception you know past
performance is pretty indicate
indicative I destroyed that a future
performance and so far from inceptions
we've done quite well and there's
nothing
uh the fact that we're gonna be we are
going to be the asset in the uh series
called trillions that's going to be
produced by Mars Callahan and Jonathan
Sanger who did the mission impossible
series
that's great for PR and marketing but
doesn't tell me anything about like the
longevity of the coin and like the
utility of the coin and the
acceptability of the coin only time will
tell like we can but I'm talking about
the uh the use cases of being able to do
that I mean you don't just snap your
fingers and it happens I'm sorry
it's incremental wow I have it off
um it's incremental
um but the fact is that this is a huge
deal that we're going to be in as 100
million dollar you know shopping cart
right that we're going to be uh uh our
gold partner is going to be accepting
epic cash I love that I think that's
awesome you know and and so we have done
we're so undiscovered yet this is what
there's going to be a few of you out
there that are that are that are smart
we're going to actually listen to uh to
what I've presented and not just poo poo
it because it's not Bitcoin and those of
you who actually go to epiccash.com and
actually you know try to uh roll up your
sleeves and learn a little bit about it
that's what uh I don't know the what
what is the word confirmation bias I get
that's what I get from the BTC community
and I know I'm never going to be popular
in that Community but I don't care you
said I wasn't popular you saw you saw no
you are very popular no you said I was
unpublished yeah you weren't getting you
were one of the top five
um uh disappointing schillers oh really
according to who that's so interesting I
I I I I'll find it afterwards oh where'd
you see that on Twitter uh yeah it was
on Twitter and who who's the uh bit boy
he was the worst right he has he has a
bad idea number five who else who else
was I did I have the honor of sharing
the stage with I'll have to look but
yeah it was and and I felt kind of good
about that I'm like wow Leia's getting
[__] from you know the tribe the tribe
the good old tribe yeah and that's I'm
sitting here
saying no that's that's our layout oh
well thank you
I'm for you because you are pro-liberty
I'm pro-freedom I'm Pro Liberty all of
this I don't do identity politics or I
you know and and that is being dogmatic
and tribal about crypto right like I I
love Bitcoin
um but I'm open to what else there is um
I haven't yet been impressed by anything
else yet but I'm open-minded and you
know let's it just means I've done a
real shitty job no it means sharing it
means it means that epic cash has only
been around for three years and so I'm
simply not convinced which is completely
fine was I convinced by Bitcoin after it
had been around for three years no I
wasn't convinced about Bitcoin after
three years I wasn't convinced about
Bitcoin after four five six I was
convinced by seven years so come back to
me in in five years okay all right let's
do this math oh yes let's do this math
all right
I'll take you up on that okay come back
to me in seven years okay I will right
now I'm telling everybody that epic cash
is a dollar 38 today when I come back in
seven years it's gonna be a hundred
thousand dollars and you'll have won
because by gosh it wasn't worth taking a
little percentage of your BTC uh uh bag
to be able to invest in that little one
that I think it had some promise I like
privacy coins I wow you can send it for
less than a penny it's scaling they have
these different use cases but you will
have showed me because you will sit back
and say you know what Uncle V you were
right I hope you are right kick butt I
wish I would have bought ten thousand
epic a hundred thousand epic when it was
under two bucks and if you did if you
did right now then maybe in those seven
years you could you could buy Britain I
could buy person uh
oh get your property get my property box
and I maybe I'll give my ago well I'll
try to buy Miami or something like that
yeah there you go whatever whatever the
place is in seven years um but no I mean
I hope you're right why not it's always
good to take some risks and diversify
um but no this has been really
interesting I will definitely I'll
definitely
um look into it more and potentially buy
some why not it's good to diversify um
but yeah I think
I'm open
as long as you know something stood the
test of time and has proved itself and
then you know I don't see why not but
thank you so much for coming on and
having this debate with me it's been
interesting great sport it's been
brilliant thank you so much for joining
us thank you where can people find you
and you can finally uh if you go to
YouTube I'm Uncle vigilante just search
for that on YouTube and then uh telegram
is where everything happens within epic
if you go to T dot me forward slash epic
cash uh and then epiccash.com and lastly
I will say everybody should go to your
app store download the Epic pay wallet
epic pay it is the best wallet in crypto
uh period it is it was created by Diego
Salazar who created uh monero's cake
wallet and it is beautiful from a UI
experience I think people really be
impressed track me down in telegram
after you do the Epic pay address DM me
and I'll send you an epic to play around
with
thanks so much for joining thank you so
much for watching if you enjoyed this
video don't forget to hit the like
button and subscribe as we have a lot
more crypto content coming stay tuned
and we'll see you all next week